welcome back to the think media podcast
Sean Cannell here and we are in our
YouTube Secrets series talking about the
perfect video recipe today's episode is
brought to you by
ytsecrets.com the second edition of
YouTube Secrets is out now and you can
check out links and some cool stuff in
the show notes of every episode but
we're talking about the perfect video
recipe after posting thousands of videos
helping tens of thousands of people grow
their YouTube channels get silver play
buttons accomplish their goals grow
their businesses get more leads and
customers so many different goals that
people have when it comes to YouTube but
it comes down to a recipe though of how
do you get reach how do you get
discovered how do you get recommended in
the YouTube algorithm and after
interviewing experts and studying the
best of the best we've distilled it down
into four ingredients it's the big idea
it's the hook it's the content and it's
the transition and you can check out the
archives of the think media podcast to
check out part one and two but in three
here we're talking about content and
again I think of these ingredients like
cooking in the kitchen and let me know
are you a cooker yourself are you an
eater you know or do you like to eat
more or cook more or both and um you
know when you first start cooking if you
have if you don't have those skills
sometimes you make mistakes you overcook
the chicken the oven you left it in too
long you added too much salt and that
can be a lot of our experiences when it
comes to YouTube as well your first
video is your worst video you know you
the audio was messed up you were kind
your voice was kind of high because you
were sort of nervous
um you know you you had a weird kind of
twitch you know happening on your face
because you were nervous like whatever
was like you you wore the wrong really
Liney shirts maybe like I'm wearing
right now and it like showed up on
camera weird yeah the video was lit
weird you're gonna make mistakes but
over time as you keep working the recipe
as you keep mastering the ingredients
and as you also keep learning how to
cook up the ingredients you know when
you're cooking it's not just about the
ingredients themselves it's about the
temperature of the stove it's about how
long do you leave it in it's about the
order it's about the Cadence and
YouTube's similar creating content is no
easy thing and so that's why we've
designed this recipe and so after you've
done uh the big idea in quick recap and
that's a great topic a great title great
thumbnail and then you've really crafted
your hook which is the first 30 seconds
to a minute plus of your video then you
of course get into the core content and
this is really everything I mean
everything leading up to this point was
critical because no one's going to care
about the content if they don't click on
the video in the first place or if they
don't keep watching and you don't
convince them to continue watching
through the first few seconds of your
video but now you're into the main
substance this is the meat and the
potatoes right and so here's your goal
you can use these four tips to double
the views on your next YouTube video
number one quickly deliver on the
promise you made on the title okay and
so now that you're into the content a
mistake you can make is taking too much
time to go off on rabbit trails
to get distracted the more quickly you
deliver on the promise you make on your
YouTube title the better and this is
actually a way to summarize success on
YouTube make a promise in the title and
deliver it in the video
success on YouTube isn't because you
have the best camera the best lighting
there have been times when I was
researching and pursuing the purchase
of a pressure watcher
in fact now that I think about it that
pressure washer that I purchased
has actually been stolen for years now
by Kyle Anderson on the think media team
but I digress
I was pursuing what pressure washer
should I buy and I started to look up
different brands and I found this Honda
pressure washer and I started to go to
YouTube and the video I found about it
was from somebody who had a really cool
shop they had a nice Barn you know where
they had their various tools and they
were breaking down all the tools all the
aspects and the features and the
different setting levels and the
different nozzles of this pressure
washer now I can't I'll never forget
this video I've never seen a more shaky
sketchy horribly shot video or shot on a
smartphone he's like on one hand he's
using the gun and pressure washers are
kind of use a lot of pressure a lot of
you know force on that so it's hard to
do with one hand he's trying to film
with the other hand it kind of looks
like maybe he had two three four five
drinks before he filmed the video I mean
it's shaky like things are crazy the
audio is not the best in the world but I
was watching this video I didn't care
about those things the promise in the
title was like what is the best Honda
pressure washer and clearly I could see
that actually he knew what he was is
talking about and I was getting answers
to my questions
so sometimes people overthink YouTube
like make a promise in the title and
deliver on the promise in the content
the mistake here is adding too much
fluff around it like just having other
stuff like hey you're not getting to the
point why are you bringing this up why
do I need to know that Kyle stole your
pressure washer like what does that have
to do with the story I don't know and so
this is a longer podcast my friend this
is not an optimized perfectly dialed in
YouTube video this is a video podcast
let's stay focused quickly deliver on
the promise you made on the title trim
the fluff make your video half short and
twice strong tip number two is prepare
and outline your points ahead of time
thank God and one of the reasons why I
hope this content is halfway decent
is that I have an outline I'm looking to
I'm looking at on my laptop right now
now if you're on the audio podcast
what you don't see is that on my desk is
a stopwatch to keep me as concise as
possible I'm at six minutes and five
seconds right now at the recording of
this I've got my laptop and I know what
episode I'm on of our podcast I've got
the the big idea these are four tips
that'll double your views and then I've
got my four points number one quickly
deliver on the promise you made on the
title number two prepare and outline
your points
it's a meta example but it's I'm showing
up organized so there is substance and
structure to this content so that also
you can walk away as a viewer or a
listener and actually walk away with
four clear tips huge mistake I see a lot
of people make is they kind of just hit
record and they just they just kind of
randomly communicate listen sometimes
that might work there maybe is a moment
where you get something off your chat
your chest you kind of rant a little bit
and that emotion's powerful and every
once in a while we'll see a YouTube
video where someone's just sharing right
from the heart and there that has a time
and place but typically prior planning
prevents poor performance so just
prepare and outline points ahead of time
if it's entertainment content bring a
structure to it every good movie has a
story structure to it there's character
development there's the conflict there's
building tension right there's conflict
resolution
um there's a structure to it there's a
beginning there's a middle there's an
end and so for think about what is the
structure of your content it's going to
be a lot better and it's going to help
you get more views higher audience
retention which will ultimately trigger
the YouTube algorithm the third tip for
improving your content is use visuals
now this is a real practical tip if
you're not video editing you can still
use visuals if you're just live
streaming you can still use visuals what
do I mean this could be a whiteboard
like one of the ways that I watch a show
I watch one rental at a time it's a
really cool uh real estate kind of based
Channel but the Creator there he does
What's called the daily financial news
what he does is he streams every morning
around 7 00 a.m Pacific Standard time
and he's in front of a whiteboard and he
writes out that eight to nine headlines
and topics he wants to deliver it's
about 10 minutes long and it's
incredibly valuable and he's speaking
out of his skill set and his knowledge
and so he hits go live he delivers the
information he often he'll do it on the
road too he committed to going a
thousand days in a row doing it so even
if he was traveling or it's the weekend
he committed to doing it so sometimes
he's sitting in a chair and he has
number two he's outlined his points so
he'll deliver it off a sticky note or
off a notepad
and so there's a structure to all of the
financial news that he wants to deliver
um but when he's in his Studio he has
his white board and it gives him
structure right it also gives the
audience something to look at what's
coming up so that's one way to do it
another way to do it is also is note
cards and what do I mean if you have
four or five points in your video you
can write the points on note cards and
hold them up one at a time and that's
also keeps something visual happening so
you're not just talking on camera with
nothing else happening this is why in
films or in drama or in theater they use
props is there any props that you can
include in your video visuals so again
even if you don't do any fancy editing
you can pre-plan visuals that will make
your video more interesting now another
way to do visuals would be kind of like
having a slide deck I live stream with a
software called streamium art you of
course could do this with zoom or any
other live streaming software and I'm
able to share slides which is kind of
like a web presentation a webinar which
is a web seminar right and I have a
slide deck that I make in PowerPoint or
you could just use Google Slides or
um you know Apple's presenter software
whatever it's called and you can use
different visuals again it makes it more
interesting for the viewer now this
doesn't just mean you do this for live
streaming although what's nice about it
is you usually you're not editing video
and live streaming so it's a way to
bring in more visuals when you are but
even if you were to record with visuals
sometimes people put a TV behind them
and they click through slides like a
presentation and then you take that 18
minute or 32 minute presentation edit
that Down chop your ums out chop out the
you know the weak parts or the parts
where you messed up and nevertheless the
visuals powered up the content what's
our goal here
with the big idea with the hook with the
big idea we're trying to get people to
click on the video with the hook we're
trying to get keep them watching for the
first 30 seconds now with the content
we're trying to keep them watching till
the end
so we want to be quickly delivering on
the promise we want a strong outline and
a structure to the video so it stays
interesting and organized and then if we
have visuals there's even more reasons
to keep the viewer in gauge which brings
us to number four and that is video
editing
video editing is one of the absolute
best ways I believe it is an essential
way that typically when you study most
viral videos when you study most of the
content that's winning on YouTube today
it is it has video editing there's just
nobody can be as good extemporaneously
or just straight through communicating
than they can be compared to when
they're edited when you're when you edit
the video you can cut out breaks and ums
and mistakes you can you can trim down
the fluff you can cut out whole sections
but more importantly you can also add
graphics or extra video clips you can
intersperse not just a little bit of you
talking but maybe a clip and an example
you can edit together Vlog style
education videos meaning you could talk
a little bit in your living room and
then you're in your kitchen and then
you're outside and then you're in the
car it's more interesting when you
include video editing and so embracing
video editing learning it it can be a
challenge here's your as a listener and
Watcher of this podcast you either got
to learn it yourself spend some time
doing it hire somebody delegate it but
if you really want to power up your
content you really want to invest in
video editing it's a key it's going to
be a key to holding the viewer attention
and Studies have really shown that
actually you want to the best YouTube
videos they change the scene every three
to five sec seconds so there's a lot
happening like it's and and there's a
there's when it comes to video editing
sometimes it can feel forced it's a
whole art form like it could sometimes
feel forced and kind of it takes away
from the content but when there's good
timing and there's a good Cadence to it
and they're the editor themself has a
good sense of when Cuts should be and
and uh the the smoothness of it all
it could change everything and so jump
Cuts transitions Graphics extra video
clips once when you take your content to
that level now your perfect video recipe
is going to another level now you're
going from just you know a one star
breakfast diner to a five-star
restaurant experience and you start
getting five star results when it comes
to uh YouTube views YouTube subscribers
and so
um which of the perfect video recipe
elements do you need to work on most or
maybe all of them in recap in part one
we talked about the big idea part two
the hook this is part three we're
talking about leveling up your content
and then in the next episode we're going
to be talking about the transition and
today's episode is brought to you by
ytsecrets.com the second edition of
YouTube Secrets is out in addition in in
the content ingredient there is actually
10 different spices see what we did
there and so there's not just the big
ingredients but there's 10 different
spices of how you can also spice up your
content and make it even better and so
um that is for a conversation for
another day or you can find that inside
of the book YouTube Secrets second
edition is what it's called you can
check out links in the show notes and if
you've been getting value out of this
rating reviewing or liking this podcast
episode means the world to myself and
the think media team as well as maybe
sharing this with somebody who would get
value from it do not miss episode number
four
um of this series do not miss part four
which is the final ingredient and it's
so important and it's a major mistake
that a lot of people are doing that is
hurting their YouTube success and so
that is coming soon or depending on when
you're watching this it's already in the
archives of the podcast thank you for
checking out this episode my name is
Sean Cannell rhymes with YouTube channel
and I will see you or connect with you
in the next episode
foreign